foreign hypersport Industries is a auto
reconditioning firm essentially they're
a vendor for carvana or they were a
vendor for carvana that does all the
Cosmetic work on cars that carvana sells
to customers so when carvana buys used
cars before it flips them to customers
it has to make sure those cars look good
that you know they're cleaned out that
any dings and paint scrapes and wheel
issues are taken care of hypersport
between 2017 and until last year were
the key vendor working in carvana's
facilities taking care of all of these
things so according to the eight carvana
employees most of them former employees
who I spoke to hypersport led by Daniel
Cerna were essentially bilking carvana
of money through a variety of means the
primary one was through a duplicate
invoice scheme and which hypersport
would charge carvana multiple times for
the same repair and these invoices were
being processed despite internal
complaints according to those former
carvana employees I spoke to secondly
hypersport was basically taking
advantage of the fact that carvana had
all of the tools and supplies and paint
in-house that was needed for them to
repair the cars that they were working
on because hypersport shared these
reconditioning facilities with carvana
they had access to all of these supplies
that they needed but according to the
employees I spoke to hypersport
frequently failed to reimburse carvana
for those supplies
we should back up a little bit to give
the full story of kind of carvana's
reconditioning History the company was
founded in 2012 as a division within a
used car dealership called drive time it
was spun off into its own entity in 2014
and between 2014 and 2017 carvana relied
on the reconditioning facilities that
drive time had come 2017 when carvana
goes public Suddenly It's armed with
over 200 million dollars in fresh IPO
proceeds so it starts building its own
reconditioning facilities and between
2017 and last year it built over a dozen
across the country the first one that
had opened was in Tolson Arizona suburb
of Phoenix this facility was operational
in September 2017. hypersport had been
Incorporated in Arizona two months
earlier this facility was the first one
to integrate hypersport into its work
line the carvana employees I spoke with
many of them really enjoyed their time
working at carvana this was a high
growth company over a number of years it
was a place that empowered people to
rise within the organization that being
said they were disturbed by what they
were seeing with hypersport and I think
they were particularly unsettled that
their complaints internally went
unaddressed this was a problem that
according to my sources went on for a
number of years and that it was systemic
in the operations of carvana's
reconditioning facilities
Daniel Cerna did not respond to requests
for comment nor did his brother Jose
Garcia Cerna hypersport did Issue a
statement to me in February denying that
it had ever defrauded or sought to
defraud carvana but when I reached out
more recently with a more detailed list
of the allegations provided they did not
respond they're my request for comment
we don't know who ultimately owns
hypersport we do know that an individual
named Jose Alejandro Garcia Cerna was
the registered agent for a number of
these hypersport subsidiaries set up in
different states we know through a
public records search that this
individual appears to have a brother
named Daniel Garcia Cerna who appears to
be the same Daniel Cerna identified by
the eight former carvana employees I
spoke to who was overseeing hypersports
alleged nefarious activities when I
first reached out to hypersports lawyers
back in Feb February raising some of the
allegations that I had heard they denied
that any of these individuals were
beneficial owners and that was on the
record so it seems likely that Daniel
Cerna is not on paper a beneficial owner
but it does beg the question who does
own hypersport is it his brother Jose
Serna is it other associates who are
working with them that remains unclear
carvana did not respond to a detailed
list of questions that I send through
prior to publication of my article
foreign so I first wrote about carvana
in May of 2022 right at the beginning of
the company's sort of downturn but it
was just after that article that I got a
call from somebody who identified
himself as a painter in one of carvana's
reconditioning facilities he had a sort
of note of alarm in his voice which
caught my attention he described to me
this sort of unbelievable series of
allegations involving hypersport this
vendor which I had never heard about to
that point and he had identified Daniel
Cerna as somebody who had just been Let
Go by carvana over connection to
hypersport after that initial call it
sort of set me off and made me want to
look into this but it took a long time
to identify who the actual people were
who would set up hypersport that it was
a seeming relative of Daniels who was
involved in setting up these companies
as well as just speaking with an number
of other carvana employees who could
verify these allegations made by this
individual carvana's had a tough time
over the last few years during the early
days of the pandemic they had an
incredible boom their stock market
valuation went through the roof it was a
historically strong used car market
thanks in large part to the near zero
interest rate policy set by the FED as
well as the supply chain issues that
were causing there to be fewer new cars
for sale so carvana really rode that
boom it's controlling shareholder Ernest
Garcia the second the father of the CEO
Ernest Garcia III during this period he
sold 3.6 billion dollars worth of stock
so he really timed his sale of carvana
stock fantastically more recently the
company has been struggling on a number
of fronts there are a number of short
sellers betting against the stock the
company has multiple billion dollars
worth of outstanding debt in addition to
the financial difficulties carvana faces
a number of legal problems the Garcias
are both being sued personally for a
stock sale that they arrange for
themselves in 2020 the company is being
sued for alleged failures to give
customers titles to their vehicles among
enough a number of other lawsuits
foreign
[Music]